Alvin has some capabilities that it
didn't have before
a new design was based on the premise
that ultimately we would like the
vehicle to go to 6,500 meters which
would allow us to reach about 98% of the
seafloor rather than the 60 to 63
percent the sub has a bunch of sensors
that makes it aware of where it is in
space and we added an additional
thruster it makes a big difference to
the kind of area you can cover actually
a lot of the technological advances
we've made have been supported by space
programs are interested in the origins
and evolution of life on our planet and
thinking about life beyond Earth you
know not just on our own planet but what
could of life look like in the beginning
of Mars history or a Beneatha you're
roping ocean or something like that
hydrogen electrons are otherworldly
Alvah does a lot of work in the Pacific
Northwest because a number of
hydrothermal vents that are there so you
have these tall structures and taller
than like the Cathedral of Notre Dame in
Paris and I've had the privilege of
diving on those and it's amazing to
basically fly the sub up the face of one
of these structures and see all the
different microbes and animals alike
that live awfully kind of tough living
at the sea floor except where you have
these areas where there's this new
production of carbon magma in the crust
is heating water that water is reacting
with the rocks and becoming kind of
nutrient rich and animal communities and
organisms are using the energy of that
water instead of getting energy from the
Sun you get microbes that are harnessing
energy from underwater volcanoes
building in differences
kind of from the bottom up is suppose
the top down we've seen footage of when
Mount st. Helens erupted for example
that huge plume of ash and spread around
our planet you know so you could think
about these big plumes coming out of
these hydrothermal vents and there have
been a couple studies and trace this
hydrothermal plume thousands of miles
alvin gives us the opportunity
go down and really look at what's out so
without Alvin who knows how long it
would have taken us to discover
hydrothermal systems but it's a
relatively young field mainly what the
scientists really want to do or collect
samples and they want a sample from that
spot the VM was really a sampling
machine so it might be measuring
chemicals the articles that are required
shooting light out and measuring the
back scatter how much comes back Alvin
was set up so that the scientist can
dream up whatever they want to put on
for you
I would describe what we're doing is
basic researches learning things about
our planet in our environment that we
didn't know before at that interface
between the Earth's interior and the
hydrosphere that chemical exchange has
an impact on global climate systems some
of those correlate very well with we've
had periods of mass extinction research
in the oceans it's directly relevant to
people's lives the Rd that we do is
hugely important to prepare ourselves
for future
you